[Ruth] "It's perfect." [Vendor] "You don't
really think of goats and cookies together do ya?
My husband he says it's
because they're satanic goats.
I don't even think the
devil eats cookies does he?"
Hey guys, Pete here. Today i'll be talking about
the first part of Ozark Season 4 which was just
released on Netflix. Because this is part one
of two that will make up the final season it
seemed unlikely that the Byrdes would get
out from under the cartel, but they were
so close. Because Marty is extremely good at what
he does, and Wendy has now gone full Heisenberg,
it was necessary to introduce some new characters
to derail their plans and to add some internal
conflict in the family with Jonah changing sides
and deciding to work with Ruth and Darlene.
We saw how one of those new characters, Javi,
undermined their chance to get free and clear
during part one, and saw the other, a private
investigator named Mel Sattsm, emerged to probably
serve a similar role in part two. I'll be getting
into all of that plus what happened at the end
right after this quick spoiler warning. If you
haven't watched all seven episodes of Ozark
season 4 part 1 then this video won't be for you,
and with that out of the way let's get into it.
I do want to mention that the season starts with
a flash forward to the entire family together
in the minivan where they all seem to be getting
along. there's talk of 48 more hours and calling
for the moving company, but a truck veers into
their lane and when they swerve to avoid it they
crash rolling the van on the side of the
road. we never revisit this scene in the
seven episodes that follow so what's going on here
and when it happens remains a question mark. the
present storyline picks up right after the season
3 finale and I mean right after as in the Byrdes
have yet to wash Helen's brains out of their hair.
after they do that we meet Omar Navarro's nephew
Javier Elizondro aka Javi and learned that
he's well-spoken and eager to play a larger
role in running the family business. he went to
university in Chicago and was close with Helen
and later says that he voted to kill them instead
of her when that came up. he also brings up
Darlene Snell which means that the Byrdes are now
tasked with getting her to shut down her operation
and later Navarro backs him up on this he explains
that if he shows any weakness Javi could make a
move to try to take over. he also tells the Byrdes
that he wants them to set up a deal with their FBI
contacts. he'll give up his cartel but he wants to
be able to move freely between the US and Mexico
and he's essentially looking for immunity for
all of his crimes. they tell him that there's
no way that they can make that happen and he
reminds them that they don't really have a
choice. the bright side is that if they pull it
off they'll be free of their obligation to him
and that sets up what they have to try to do for
the rest of the season. after Ben's death at the
end of season three Ruth Langmore stopped
working for Marty and threw in with Darlene
and her cousin Wyatt. at the beginning of season
4 she buys the Lazy-O motel to launder their money
and this is where we first met her and her cousins
when the Byrdes came to town in season one.
she's got a problem though she knows how to run
Marty's laundering software but doesn't know
how to make her own. this is what will eventually
lead to her teaming up with Jonah who's developed
software at age 14 which is impressive even if the
actor has outgrown his role in the past couple of
years. he's still upset about learning from Helen
that his parents had Ben killed and after Wendy
decides to take the hard approach in trying to
bend him to her will he goes full team Ruth for
all seven episodes. on the other hand Charlotte
is completely on board with the family business
and has even decided she's going straight into it
rather than going to college. beyond reaching out
to Wyatt and threatening Helen's daughter Erin
at one point they don't give her much to do in
these episodes, but i couldn't help noticing
that the actor made a real attempt to copy some
Laura Linney's mannerisms which shows how much
she's starting to take after her mother. Helen's
disappearance has brought another new character
to town Mel is a private investigator that says he
was hired by her husband to get her signature on
divorce paperwork. he has a habit of showing up at
inopportune times and after observing the Byrdes
for a while he starts to believe that Ben might
have been involved with helen's disappearance. of
course ben is dead so he's barking up the wrong
tree but he may turn out to be a real problem for
marty and wendy. when they looked into his past
they learned that he was a cop that was really
good at his job before his substance abuse issues
led to him getting caught in the evidence room and
losing his badge. for most of the season wendy is
making big moves in her attempt to turn them into
one of the most powerful families in the midwest
and that includes working with a pharmaceutical
company whose reputation has taken a hit for their
role in helping to create the opioid crisis. that
helped her put together a 150 million dollar war
chest after she stole jim out from under charles
wilkes and made him their full-time attorney. i
compared her to walter white earlier because this
has completed her transformation that started back
in season 2. it's clear this has all gone to her
head and she makes two questionable decisions that
will make things difficult for the family going
forward. the first was to use her brother ben
for what she says is good pr saying that he had a
drug problem and using the fact that he's missing
to her advantage. this causes problems with marty
and with ruth and that brings darlene into things
to try to stick up for wyatt's cousin. the second
is that she tries to force jonah into coming back
to the family and when that doesn't work she goes
as far as trying to get him arrested. by the time
we get to episode 7 marty has mostly been able to
neutralize javi whose uncle is actively working
on a deal with the fbi behind his back. he had
convinced navarro to give Maya information that
would lead to seizures to keep her happy and that
worked until Javi rigged one of those with a bomb.
this led to navarro deciding to give him up. he
told him that he was stepping aside and that he'd
be the new boss and then set a meeting with the
fbi. jim is on hand to explain all of that and
that omar will provide the necessary information
to neutralize his cartel entirely. the problem
there is that the fbi has been enjoying the extra
money they've been getting through those cash
seizures and have decided that they want him to
continue being a drug lord for five more years.
after that they can grant him immunity from
prosecution in the US. since he's already told
Javi that he was taking over it means that he
would have to kill him and the fbi knows that
and they're okay with that. maya is not okay with
it though she can't believe what she's hearing
and her boss has to explain that they're trying to
collaborate as a way to make progress and that she
has to think about the big picture because if
they take navarro down someone else will just
rise up to take his place. maya says sarcastically
that she thought they were just trying to justify
five more years of seizures and the truth is
likely somewhere in the middle but it undermines
everything she believed about her job. in the
end navarro realizes he doesn't have any other
options. he knows he'll likely get screwed over in
the end but he agrees to the five-year deal. the
fbi tells marty and wendy that they'll take over
their role with the cartel and thanks them for
their service to america and they were just that
close to getting out but it wasn't meant to be.
javi finds out that shaw pharmaceuticals was
able to make their production goals even while
he was withholding his product. he calls Clare who
tells him that marty provided a stop gap and when
pressed gives up ruth's description. things hadn't
been going good for her because darlene found out
that she did the deal with marty and had also
killed frank senior in a rage and so ruth and
wyatt were going to take off together and she
took the opportunity to tell frank jr about what
happened to his father. because wendy contacted
social services and told them about darlene's
heart attack though they were coming to take zeke
and when wyatt found out about that he wasn't able
to leave her he decided to marry her to keep that
from happening. ruth is initially upset because
they were that close to getting out themselves but
she eventually accepts it and then has to go and
tell frank jr that he can't kill her. at the same
time things take a real turn for the Byrdes when
navarro returns to his plane where he's surrounded
by cops and taken into custody. maya went behind
her boss's back and made a move against him and
now there's nothing that they can really do about
it. this worries marty and wendy because they're
afraid that Javi's gonna think that they were
involved because maya was. he sends charlotte to
go get jonah and take him into hiding at buddy's
mausoleum and when she goes to the lazy-o to pick
him up mel is there and he overhears part of their
conversation. while they're hiding they do have a
talk where she tries to reassure him that they'll
always stick together and that they'll always
be fine marty and wendy are able to get the
fbi to consider a deal with Javi now that omar is
locked up they need him to contact his nephew and
tell him to do it though and he almost kills marty
before wendy can talk him into it the plan is that
if he makes a deal then navarro will be extradited
to mexico where he can walk away from all of this
before he leaves he warns that if he isn't out of
jail in 48 hours nelson has orders to kill them
wyatt and darlene have their wedding at the same
time the fbi is explaining the deal to Javi it's
changed to 10 years of running the cartel instead
of 5 and includes extra stipulations which all
kind of backs up what maya was saying and we see
mel call her on the phone after he sees her on the
news and tells her that he's a big fan which hints
at a team up in the second half of the season
darlene and wyatt come home to find hobby waiting
in their living room now that he works for the fbi
he feels emboldened and he shoots and kills both
of them and walks out leaving zeke crying in the
background ruth was headed over there to give them
their gift and tell them goodbye and she's the one
who discovers the bodies she grabs zeke and drives
away crying and initially thinks it's frank jr
but when she talks to him and realizes he didn't
do it she heads straight to the bird's house
she demands to know who killed wyatt and they're
reluctant to say anything now that they're relying
on the deal between the fbi and hobby in one final
act of rebellion against wendy jonah tells her
and when marty pleads with her not to get involved
with hobby she screams if you want to stop me
you're gonna have to effing kill me which you
have to imagine wendy is already considered
she takes her shotgun and storms out and gets into
her truck with zeke and takes off the episode ends
with her driving away thinking about what she's
going to do and then breaking down screaming
part one ends with a pretty big cliffhanger and
the unresolved mystery of the car crash at the
beginning that certainly hints at the family
coming back together enough that they're ready
to get out again but there's a lot that needs
to happen to get them there if you think about
it ruth really has lost it all now that she's
lost wyatt it's clear that marty still has a
sense of wanting to look after her but after what
happened with ben there's no chance she's going to
listen to them and who else is there to talk sense
into her after his deal with the fbi javi's in a
powerful position and it's hard to imagine that
he won't abuse that so a lot of great stuff to
set up the second part where anything could still
happen and the wild cards of mel and maya still
out there to throw things off post ben wendy has
really turned into the most interesting character
to watch there were so many points in these
episodes where she seems so absolutely ruthless
i liked it when the birds sort of blackmailed
navarro saying that if anything happens to them
his kids won't be able to access the money they
put aside he actually took the high road imagine
sitting down with a cartel boss and you come away
looking like the dishonorable one also liked the
twist with the fbi and how they were portrayed
there's a nice parallel with all the dirt wendy
was doing and her counseling claire telling
herself that she'd be piling good on top of good
to make up for all the bad while at the same time
telling her son who she tried to get arrested that
he needs to grow up because this is america and
no one cares how you got your fortune the family
is divided and nothing that happened in the final
moment seemed to put jonah and wendy on the path
to reconciliation i also wonder how jim will feel
about working with the birds after what went down
and what that might mean for the foundation all
things considered things were progressing on that
front and the fbi did relieve them of their
money laundering duties for the cartel marty
even pulled the trigger on the office in chicago
before they found out about darlene and wyatt
ruth is alone and wants vengeance and i suppose
as we near the end of the series the question will
be who makes it out it will be interesting to see
how the different birds approach her situation
and where things will land by the end of part
two and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what you
thought about part one how you think things
are gonna play out and check back in a couple
of days because i'll follow this up with the
second video with all my questions about part two
we're getting to the end of the series so let me
know what you think's gonna happen please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon